so I want to talk to you about the
Forgotten Medal to me they're the
students co-workers and plane all
regular folks who are often overlooked
because they're seen as neither
exceptional nor problematic
they're the kids we think we can ignore
because their needs for support don't
seem particularly urgent they're the
co-workers who actually keep the engines
of our organizations running but who
aren't seen as the innovators who drive
excellence in many ways we overlook the
folks in the middle because they don't
keep us up awake at night wondering what
crazy thing they're going to come up
with next and the truth is that we've
come to rely on their complacency and
sense of disconnection because it makes
our work easier you see I know a little
bit about the Forgotten medal as a
junior high school student I hung out in
the middle for a long time I had been a
good student but seventh grade was a
game changer I spent my days gossiping
passing notes generally goofing off with
my friends I spent my homework time on
the phone
reviewing each day's events and in many
ways although I was a typical
twelve-year-old girl my ambivalence
about my education led to pretty average
grades luckily for me my mother
understood something important and that
was that my location was not my
destination as a former research
librarian and an educator my mother knew
that I was capable of accomplish
a lot more but she also understood that
because I was a young black woman in
America I might not have opportunities
out of the middle
if she wasn't intentional about creating
them so she moved me to a different
school she signed me up for leadership
activities in my neighborhood and she
began to talk to me more seriously about
college and career options I could
aspire to my mother's formula for
getting me out of the middle was pretty
simple
she started with high expectations she
made it her business to figure out how
to set me up for success she held me
accountable and along the way she
convinced me that I had the power to
create my own story that formula didn't
just help me get out of my seventh-grade
slump
I used it later on in New York City when
I was working with kids who had a lot of
potential but not a lot of opportunities
to go to and complete college you see
high-performing students tend to have
access to additional resources like
summer enrichment activities internships
and an expansive curriculum that takes
them out of the classroom and into the
world in ways that look great on college
applications but we're not providing
those kinds of opportunities for
everyone and the result isn't just that
some kids miss out I think we as a
society miss out too you see I've got a
crazy theory about the folks in the
middle I think there's some unclaimed
winning lottery tickets in the middle
I think the cure for cancer and the path
to world peace might very well reside
there now it's a former middle school
teacher I'm not saying that magically
every
suddenly become gonna become an A
student but I also believe that most
folks in the middle are capable of a lot
more and I think people stay in the
middle because that's where we've
relegated them to and sometimes that's
just where they're kind of chilling
while they figure things out all of our
journeys are made up of a series of rest
stops accelerations losses and wins we
have a responsibility to make sure that
one's racial gender cultural and
socio-economic identity is never the
reason you didn't have access out of the
middle so just as my mother did with me
I began with high expectations with my
young people and I started with the
question I stopped asking kids hey do
you want to go to college I started
asking them what college would you like
to attend you see the first question the
first question leaves a lot of vague
possibilities open but the second
question says something about what I
thought my young people were capable of
on a basic level it assumes that they're
gonna graduate from high school
successfully it also assumed that they
would have the kinds of academic records
that could get them college and
university admissions and I'm proud to
say that the high expectations worked
well black and Latin Mac students
nationally tend to graduate from college
and six years or less at a percent of 38
we were recognized by the College Board
for our ability not to just get kids
into college but to get them through
college
but I also understand that high
expectations are great but it takes a
little bit more than that you wouldn't
ask a pastry chef to bake a cake without
an oven and we should not be asking the
folks in the middle to make the leap
without providing them with the tools
strategies and support they deserve to
make progress in their lives a young
woman I had been mentoring for a long
time Nicole came to my office one day
after her guidance counselor looked at
her pretty strong transcript and
expressed utter shock and amazement that
she was even interested in going to
college what the guidance counselor
didn't know was that through her
community Nicole had had access to
college prep work SAT prep and
international travel programs not only
was College in her future but I'm proud
to say that Nicole went on to earn two
master's degrees after graduating from
Purdue University
[Applause]
we also made it our business to hold our
young people accountable but also to
instill a sense of accountability in
those young people to themselves to each
other to their families and to their
communities we doubled down on asset
based youth development we went on
leadership retreats and did high ropes
courses and low ropes courses and
tackled life's biggest questions
together the result was that the kids
really bought into the notion that they
were accountable for achieving these
college degrees it was so gratifying to
see the kids calling each other and
texting each other to say hey why are
you late for SAT prep and what are you
packing for the college tour tomorrow we
really work to kind of make college the
thing to do we began to create programs
on college campuses and events that
allow young people to really visualize
themselves as college students and
college graduates me and my staff rocked
our own college gear and had lots of fun
healthy competition about whose school
was better than who use the kids really
bought into it and they began to see
that something more was possible for
their lives not only that they could
look around at that College going
community and see kids who came from the
same backgrounds and the same
neighborhoods and who were aspiring to
the same things that sense of belonging
was really key and it showed up in a
remarkable beautiful way one day when we
were in the Johannesburg Airport waiting
to go through customs on our way to
Botswana for a service learning trip I
saw a group of kids kind of huddled in a
circle
usually with teens that means
something's going on
so I kind of walked up behind the kids
to figure out what they were talking
about they were comparing passport
stamps and they were dreaming out loud
about all the other countries they plan
to visit in the future and seeing these
young people from New York City go on to
not just become college students but to
participate in study abroad programs and
to then take jobs around the world was
incredibly gratifying when I think of my
kids and all the doctors lawyers
teachers social workers journalists and
artists who came from our little nook in
New York City I hate to think of what
would have happened if we hadn't
invested in the middle just think about
all that their communities and the world
would have missed out one this formula
for the middle doesn't just work with
young people it can transform our
organizations as well we can me be more
bold and coming up in articulating a
mission that inspires everyone we can
authentically invite our colleagues to
the table to come up with a strategy to
meet the mission we can give meaningful
feedback to folks along the way and and
sometimes most importantly make sure
that you're sharing credit for
everyone's contributions what happened
when my staff aimed high for themselves
is that what they were able to do for
young people was pretty transformational
and it's been so wonderful to look back
and see all of my former colleagues
who've gone on to get doctorates and
assumed leadership roles in other
organizations we have what it takes to
inspire and uplift the folks in the
middle we can extend love
to the people in the middle we can
challenge our own biases about who
deserves a hand up and how we can
structure our organizations communities
and institutions in ways that are
inclusive and that uphold principles of
equity because in the final analysis
what is often mistaken for a period is
really just a comma thank you
[Applause]